[Musique]
chaque fois qu'une femme fait quelque
chose d'exceptionnel et quelle est la
première à le faire elle entre dans
l'histoire c'est le cas de notre invité
aujourd'hui sa première à elle c'est
l'espace elle est encore la seule
française à y être allé c'était en 1996
à bord de la station mir puis en 2001 à
bord de la station spatiale
internationale vous connaissez forcément
celle iss tellement médiatisé par un
certain thomas pesquet d'ailleurs que
pense-t-elle de ce jeune spationautes
qui a pris sa succession
et puis que pense-t-elle de ses
milliardaires qui prennent la bille de
cosmonaute on va lui poser toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue claudie haigneré merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
sénat odon tournon thomas pasquet vous
suivez sur les réseaux sociaux vous
approuvez sa démarche de partage comme
ça avec les français y les embarquent
moi je suis très très admiratif de ce
que thomas fait dans ce partage
d'expérience en plus vous le savez c'est
un astronaute très professionnel et qui
a merveilleusement réussi ses missions
sur le plan scientifique technologique
tout ce qu'il a pu réaliser c'est un
très bel ambassadeur de notre respect
pour la planète et la montre
magnifiquement avec les photographies je
crois que de pouvoir partager presque en
temps réel en direct des choses aussi
extraordinaire si important pour
apporter de l'inspiration et je suis sûr
que la tire beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
filles et jeunes garçons vers ces
métiers puis nous fait tous réfléchir en
s'en prenant de la hauteur et en
partageant ses importants vous l'avez
dit vous le faites différemment mais
vous aussi vous partager beaucoup votre
expérience notamment pour dire aux
jeunes filles allez-y lancez vous dans
ce monde très masculin des sciences de
l'ingénierie pourquoi vous sentez que
les jeunes femmes n'osent pas
alors je pense que c'est important
aujourd'hui étant donné
ce que les outils de la science de la
technologie vont apporter pour
construire un monde on l'espère meyer
est avancé pour qu'on est tous les
talents possible les talons c'est la
diversité et cette diversité
j'ai pas pierre présentée dans milieu
des sciences dans le milieu d'ingénierie
dans le milieu du numérique également
dans le numérique c'est encore pire je
dirais que dans d'autres secteurs
puisqu'on est à 10 12 % de présence
féminine dans l'orientation vers ces
carrières on est à 20 25 % dans les
métiers de l'ingénierie les sciences
dures c'est un peu la même chose et ça
pas vraiment progressé depuis de très
nombreuses années on a nos mères nos
grands mères et puis nos aînés qui ceux
qui ont lutté sur ce sujet moi même j'y
ai contribué on a fait avancer un petit
peu les choses qui est arrivé en espèces
de plateau et aujourd'hui on est dans ce
plateau où est ben on reproduit pas
cette société cette mixité qui doit de
femmes qu'est ce que ça changerait
les approches sont pas obligatoires -
strictement les mêmes et c'est
enrichissant d'avoir des approches
différentes on est dans un monde quand
même très très complexe aujourd'hui
personne ne va trouver la solution
unique à un problème si complexe donc la
diversité et la multiplicité des regards
étaient des femmes elle apporterait
quelque chose de plus vous vous pensez à
quelque chose en particulier qu'elle
aurait que qui manquent à la science
aujourd'hui
elle apporte une façon de penser qui
leur est propre avec ce qui est
des clichés des façons de penser des
façons bousculent et peut-être certaines
choses établies elle apporte aussi des
sujets moi je le vois dans domaine de la
médecine chez médecins au départ eh bien
parfois on a regardé certains problèmes
médicaux de seo boroughs de problèmes
cardiovasculaires avec une vision soit
spécifiquement masculine soit
spécifiquement féminine donc voilà ce
sont des choses qui nous concernent tous
on a besoin de la diversité des
approches et je parlais du monde
numérique qui est cet outil qui va
écrire le monde inventé le monde de
demain il faut qu'ils soient écrits avec
toutes les marques toutes les voir
toutes les façons de penser et c'est
pour ça que j'appelle souvent les jeunes
filles à
franchir ce qui pourrait être des
barrières
intérieur parfois des barrières selon
d'autres voilà autocensure mais aussi
les barrières qui sont mises par
l'extérieur c'est la double façon
d'avancer sur ces chemins qui sont ces
chemins passionnant justement vous avez
dit un jour tout est à la portée des
femmes tout est accessible c'est comme
cela que j'ai vécu les choses ça veut
dire qu'à aucun moment pour vous le fait
d'être une femme n'a été un frein un
problème un sujet
très franchement très franchement je
peux vous répondre comme ça mais je
crois que c'est pas si simple pour avoir
le courage l'audace ans thérèse sur une
voie qui est pas une voie classique
crois qu'il faut avoir un désir très
fort à un moment donné pour surmonter
cette appréhension de quelque chose et
moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir ce rêve
d'enfant juillet 69 le premier pas de
l'homme sur la lune j'avais 12 ans
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment fasciné
marquez qui a fait mûrir en moi ce désir
de cet espace là à découvrir et donc
c'était ça le point qui m'a fait avancer
je me suis pas préoccupé de savoir
filles ou garçons des porte était
entrouverte et après j'ai eu
effectivement un petit peu cette audace
de la poussée est ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui que vous êtes une féministe
ou est ce que le mot dérange parce qu'il
est parfois associé à une forme de
bataille contre les hommes un peu
violente est ce que vous vous sentez
féministe et dans quel sens parce qu'il
ya plusieurs sens peut-être je me sens
engagé pour que les femmes puissent
effectivement prendre toute leur place
essayer tous les métiers réussir tout ce
qu'elle souhaite faire mais je ne le
fais pas contre les hommes c'est quand
on dit employer ce mot je pense que ça
nous concerne hommes et femmes pour
qu'ensemble justement cette diversité
nous enrichissent mutuellement il nous
fasse avancer donc je suis seul homme
pour exister en tant que femme veut pas
du tout au contraire on a besoin des
hommes pour exister en tant que fan
j'irai jusque jusque là et en général
quand je m'adresse justement aux jeunes
filles ou jeunes femmes dans leur métier
leur environnement professionnel
j'essaie toujours d'associer les hommes
dans cette réflexion parce que c'est
ensemble qu'on va trouver sans doute
aussi le meilleur équilibre dans cette
vie s'est épanoui cement de la vie
quitte à la fois bien sûr
l'environnement professionnel mais dieu
aussi sa vie privée sa famille la façon
dont on s'organise et ça on peut le
faire qu'avec nos compagnons avec nos
maris et avec les hommes autour de nous
vous avez parlé de ce déclic 1 2 juillet
1969 qui a été vraiment un moment
charnière dans votre vie vous avez à ce
moment-là 12 ans vous voyez ses premiers
pas sur la lune chez vous ou à la
télévision dans quel contexte ce que
j'ai lu aussi qu' il y avait eu un autre
déclic et qui était un an avant 2001
odyssée de l'espace de stanley kubrick
c'est à ce moment là que vous réalisez
que
c'est dans l'espace que vous souhaitez
aller c'est vrai que je lis et 69
vous n'avez pas encore beaucoup de
télévision à cette époque là et on était
en vacances avec mes parents il y avait
un téléviseur dans le camping on était
c'était une nuit passée dehors tous
massés devant le téléviseur et un petit
peu je dirais une fascination de
l'humanité à ce moment là il ya des
millions de personnes qui ont vécu ce
moment là il me reste gravé dans mon
esprit et c'est à partir de là que je me
suis intéressé à rabat ce milieu qui
devenaient accessibles alors qu'il était
un rêve auparavant mais ont nourri son
imaginaire avec des documentaires avec
des livres de la science fiction et avec
des fils et c'est vrai que 2000 un
espace c'est venu un petit peu après
j'étais adolescente mais c'est quelque
chose qui a mûri tout au long de mon
adolescence le cinéma on a fait partir
oui mais est-ce qu à ce moment là vous
faites une sorte de plan de carrière
vous vous dites il faut absolument que
j'aille vers les sciences j'ai lu vous
avez eu votre bac à 15 ans
j'ai cette chance effectivement des mets
beaucoup de l'école travailler donc
voilà j'étais une petite fille à la fois
curieuse et qu'il réussisse et bien à
l'école avec des facilités pour les avec
des possibilités pour les sciences mais
j'ai fait du latin et du grec très
heureuse d'avoir pu
aussi avoir ses éléments de mythologie
mes missions spatiales d'ailleurs
s'appelle cassiopée et andromède donc
voila c'était
tout un environnement qui m'a qui me
plaisait beaucoup et j'avais la
possibilité d'aller vers nous pas une
école dassault note ça n'existe pas à
l'école donc j'ai choisi de devenir
médecin médecin rhumatologue à priori
rien à voir on est d'accord si city
apporte il de compétition le
fonctionnement du corps le corps dans la
performance le corps dans la douleur le
corps de la jeune donc là et le corps en
microgravité donc non ça c'est un fils
constant dans dans mon histoire et donc
j'ai fait mes études de médecine et
s'étend en exerçant la médecine que j'ai
eu la chance de tomber sur appel à
candidatures du cnes l'agencé française
de l'espace on est en 85 à ce moment-là
1,25 grande époque d'une ambition
française et européenne dans l'espace
l'exploration habitée certains
souviennent du programme hermès de ses
stations en orbite donc voilà je me suis
dit la porte est ouverte ce qui était
pour moi un rêve peut-être être
accessible en j'y suis allé ça marchait
et du coup départ pour la russie vous
apprenez nouvelle langue vous
découvrirez aussi une nouvelle culture
est ce qu'à ce moment là c'est facile
tous les jours ou pas
rien de facile dans une aventure comme
celle là c'est beaucoup de travail c'est
de la patience et de persévérance et de
de l'entraînement c'est l'apprentissage
du russe ou et vous avez raison j'ai
parti en 92 à la cité des étoiles près
de près de moscou et à ce moment là
c'était aussi une aventure humaine est
une aventure de coopération très
particulière c'était une coopération
franco soviétique presque 92 imaginer
franco franco russe ça n'est qu'après
que l'ouverture s'est faite à d'autres
européens l'aventuré avec l'agencé
spatiale européenne puis l'aventuré avec
les américains la construction de la
station spatiale internationale en
coopération entre la russie nasa
l'agencé spatiale européenne le canada
et le japon donc c'est petit à petit que
d'une aventure très bilatérales on est
arrivés dans un une coopération
internationale je dis souvent que j'ai
eu cette chance exceptionnelle de faire
deux missions spatiales
mais j'ai vécu quinze années d'une
aventure humaine scientifique et
technique mais humaine extraordinaire
vous avez la nostalgie parfois de cette
coopération notamment franco russe avec
une tendresse particulière pour la
russie par exemple j'ai une tendresse
particulière pour les russes pour mes
compagnons pour la fraternité
pour avoir été accueillis je dirais
parmi mes héros les mythes arrivée à la
cité des étoiles ça veut dire que vous
allez vivre à côté d'eux alexis léonov
de valentina terechkova donc voilà ça
c'était tout mot toute mon enfance et
j'ai j'ai vécu avec ces gens là qui
m'ont accueilli qui m'ont formé qui
m'ont fait confiance qu'ils m'ont donné
la possibilité de voler alors bien
évidemment quand je dis aventure humaine
c'est aussi cette aventure fraternelle
avec ceux que j'ai rencontrés là-bas
wyss a raconté beaucoup et ça compte
toujours beaucoup pour moi et c'est
super que vous m'ayez parler de
valentina terechkova bhl c'est
finalement une archive si on a préparé
pour vous qui nous a été transmise par
les archives nationales qui sont nos
partenaires
dans cette émission alors je
l'expliquais pour les gens qui nous
écoutent valentina terechkova en une du
magazine france urss un numéro paru en
juin 1974 c'est la toute première femme
de l'histoire à avoir effectué un vol
spatial habité c'était en juin 1963 est
ce que vous diriez que cette femme a
ouvert la voie à toutes les femmes et
peut-être avoue d'ailleurs alors
valentina terechkova l'est effectivement
très très présente dans le monde du
spatial on se connaissait pas à l'époque
ni gagarine enchaînant 57 avec spoutnik
mais j'étais un peu petit pour que
gagarine intérêt jusqu'au 20 mai
impressionné je vous ai parlé de lui et
69 on est plutôt sur nos nos collègues
américains est le premier pas sur la sur
la lune mais valentina terechkova oui
elle est très très présente il ya eu
beaucoup d'autres femmes il faut qu'on
en parle aujourd'hui qui ont eu accès à
toutes les fonctions dans les carrières
spatiale des pilotes navette spatiale
des commandants de la station spatiale
internationale ce que l'on parle des
têtes d'affiché mais j'imagine
qu'effectivement il y avait d'autres
femmes impliquées dans ces missions
ailleurs
oui alors il n'y a pas beaucoup de
femmes quand on veut le reconnaître avec
vous aujourd'hui à peu près 600
astronautes qui ont volé et je crois
qu'il ya 66 femmes donc on a un peu
au-delà des 10% qu'on a évoqué
précédemment les choses sont en train de
bouger l' agence spatiale européenne par
exemple vous avez évoqué thomas pesquet
à ont couru une sélection pour recruter
de nouveaux astronautes pour les
missions à venir aura l'occasion d'en
parler au delà de l'orbité basse et des
stations aller vers la lune qui prépare
et mars et cette sélection eh bien on a
eu le plaisir de voir 24 % de jeunes
femmes alors qu'à mon époque dont 85 ont
été 10 % de candidates féminines 24% un
début de sélection est aujourd'hui dans
cette sélection 39 % de jeunes femmes
sont encore en lice dans cette sélection
qui aboutira à la fin de l'année 2022
donc moi je suis très heureuse de voir
que
l'exemple de ces femmes alors valentina
c'est un peu anciens mais samantha
cristoforetti guié l'astronaute
européenne aujourd'hui active qui va
voler cette année qui sera commandant de
la station spatiale internationale
oui ça fait rêver les jeunes filles je
suis heureuse qu'elle emboîte le pas et
qu'il soit là pour être sélectionné je
disais que les critères étaient très
précises pour valentina terechkova être
parachutistes avoir moins de 30 ans
faire moins d'un mètre soixante dix et
moins de 70 kg il ya toujours autant de
critères vous aviez vous ces critères
quels étaient les critères pour vous
alors il ya bien évidemment des critères
physiques physiologiques et médicaux il
faut pas être trop grand faut pas que
trop lourd en face avait vu une capsule
soyouz c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est assez restreint comme comme
volume par rapport à 20e siècle je
dirais on est aujourd'hui sur des
profils beaucoup plus large vous avez
des astronautes qui sont bas bien
évidemment des médecins des chercheurs
dans les tas de domaines des ingénieurs
en robotique en intelligence
artificielle tout autant que dans
d'autres domaines plus aéronautique vous
avez des civils et encore des militaires
donc des profils très très large on
cherche pas des superman ou des supers
baumann on cherche des gens qui vont
travailler en équipe dans des conditions
c'est vrai au style complète contraintes
confiné et qui auront cette capacité à
réussir ensemble une mission donc voilà
des gens pour le travail en équipage du
multitâche et au delà de sa formation
départ selon entraînement qui va vous
amener à vous sentir bien pour la
mission ça va vous ouvrir à des tas de
compétences variées et je vais les
acquérir et justement peut-être une
préparation mentale très fortes aussi
est ce qu'à un moment donné on a peur de
ne pas revenir on a peur de la mort où
est ce qu'on a à ce point confiance dans
les calculs qui ont précédé des telles
missions à ce point confiance dans la
science que finalement on n'a pas peur
est-ce qu'on a peur il ya une grosse
partie qui est de construire cette
confiance l'entraînement c'est cette
confiance en soi la confiance des
membres d'équipage avec lesquels on va
partir d'accords la confiance à la
réaction de son corps est effectivement
ça fait partie de la sélection et
d'entraînement et puis la confiance dans
le système technique avec lequel on va
on va travailler moi j'avoue que il y
avait toute cette analyse des risques
potentiels qui font partie de cette
aventure très technique un propulsion
une fusée trois étages de propulsion 28
10 km heure à régler dans le vide
spatial s'amarrer à une station c'est
quand même quelque chose de très très
technologique mais la connaissance du
système
l'entraînement pour simuler ce qu'on
appelle les situations non nominale là
où ça pose problème le feu à bord la
dépressurisation
la maintenance d'un appareillage qui va
pas bien donc on est formé nous sommes
les astronautes professionnels formés
bien évidemment donc on n'a pas peur ou
alors ça n'empêche pas la peur je pense
que en fait cette confiance nous donne
le courage de prendre la part de risque
qui éventuellement denrées dans une
aventure comme celle ci mais qui
existent ont beaucoup d'éléments de la
vie quotidienne et de toutes autres de
tout autre métier alors j'ai la chance
de vivre des missions tout s'est bien
passé donc je vais pas été confrontée
avec des situations difficiles à aborder
sans doute s'il y avait eu un feu à bord
c'est une dépressurisation
sûrement eu un sentiment de porsche je
peux le dire comme ça et la vie dans la
capsule racontez nous un peu la gravité
la microgravité vous disiez tout à
l'heure ce corps si léger ce rapport au
corps un nouveau rapport au corps
j'imagine oui un nouveau rapport au
corps et sans doute pas ce court j'ai
suis médecin rhumatologue heures j'aime
comprendre le fonctionnement du corps
j'ai eu beaucoup de de plaisir et je
dirais presque d'émerveillement avoir la
capacité d'adaptation de notre corps à
une situation qui est quand même pas
habituel on est des terriens dans le
champ de gravité avec un référentiel de
vertical des contrôles de posture et on
se retrouve dans cet immense volume
d'une station spatiale a utilisé les
trois dimensions à de voir un petit peu
adaptée sur le plan cognitif la façon
dont on va s'orienter mais on fait assez
rapidement et c'est ça qui est étonnant
arrivé à s'adapter à un environnement
aussi aussi particulier moi ça m'a donné
beaucoup de plaisir ça m'a même fait
réfléchir sur le plan médical ou la
façon de traiter certaines pathologies
qu'on pourrait avoir de se dire il ya
des ressorts cachés et des potentiels
qui peuvent être révélées si on pense
autrement et c'est ce qui me plaît aussi
dans l' aventure spatiale dans ce monde
si différent c'est de se dire qu'on
sortant un peu de sa boîte de penser on
peut trouver les solutions qu'on
n'aurait pas abordé si on était resté
dans notre zone de confort et ça ça fait
partie de leçons que j'ai tiré aussi de
cette aventure sens propre comme au sens
figuré pour le cloud depuis quelques
années on assiste à une série de records
plus insolites les uns que les autres
une course à l'exploit spatiale c'est
comme ça que j'ai envie d'appeler les
choses je rappelle quelques dates qui
sont très récents d'ailleurs 11 juillet
2021 richard bronson premiers
milliardaires à voler dans l'espace 20
juillet 2021 jeff bezos ce 16 septembre
2021 premier vol orbital entièrement
civil 5 octobre 2021 premier film tourné
dans l'espace 13 octobre 2021 william
shatner 90 ans le plus vieil humain a
voyagé au dessus de la ligne de karmann
sa karma n'aborde d'une fusée américaine
et j'en passe j'en passe plein d'autres
ce qui m'amène à cette question est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que l'espace
est devenu un terrain de jeu qui a
quelque chose d'un peu presque puérile
de la part de l'humain qui fait de
l'espace un terrain de jeu j'ai pas
d'autre terme
alors pour peut-être certaines de ces
personnes c'est un terrain de jeu à moi
je ne considérais pas comme ça pour moi
c'est un terrain d'exploration c'est un
terrain de chances de progrès
technologique un progrès d'avancé de nos
connaissances après c'est vrai que ces
trente années quarante années de
maîtrise de l'espace ont donné la
possibilité de l'ouvrir de le démocrate
démocratiser son accès il ya aussi des
réductions des coûts par rapport à ce
que représentaient les vous l'avez vous
vous y voyez des bienfaits ces
milliardaires s'amuser à aller dans
l'espace créé des engins pour y aller je
pense à certains moments que ces
personnes peuvent apporter leur regard
qui n'est pas un regard de professionnel
et que ça peut être différent
intéressant par contre voilà je suis pas
quelqu'un qui va souhaiter voir se
développer un tourisme de masse dans
l'espace bien évidemment parce que à la
fois cet environnement autour de notre
planète là aussi il faut le préserver il
n'y a pas que l'environnement sous êtres
monsieur eric celui et au delà de
l'atmosphère faut le préserver aussi on
parle de débris spatiaux on parle de
constellation de satellites pour
lesquels il faut réguler un petit peu
cet accès donc pour moi c'est un
tourisme de masse dans l'espace ça fait
pas partie du tout ce que de ce que
j'envisage mais par contre ça montre la
fiabilité des systèmes et je pense qu'il
peut y avoir une façon de relater
d'autres smet
raconté un regard qui peut toucher
certains qui n'étaient pas touchés par
une aventure trop vu sur le plan
scientifique et à ceux qui diraient on
est en train de dépenser des milliards
dans une conquête spatiale alors qu'on
est déjà des millions sur cette planète
à ne pas vivre décemment que répondre à
cela est ce qu on a besoin de ces
milliards ou est-ce qu effectivement
vous dit on en fait un peu trop je crois
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger il ya des
milliards qui sont consacrés au spatial
mais le spatial c'est plein de choses le
spatial c'est l'observation de la terre
les satellites de géolocalisation c'est
tout les télécommunications l'accès à
internet c'est notre vie quotidienne
peut pas vivre aujourd'hui sans ces
batteries de satellites qui nous donnent
des informations vous voyez on a un peu
perdu de vue sa l'utilité de lancer
d'autres cherchent c'est devenu
tellement présent nous faisons tellement
partie de notre quotidien
qu'effectivement c'est un petit peu
transparent et je crois qu'il faut en
parler en plus on peut en parler avec
beaucoup de fierté je dirais parce que
l'agent spatiale européenne et la france
dans l' agence spatiale européenne à
contribuer magnifiquement à ses
batteries de satellites d'observation de
la terre le système copernicus qui nous
permettent de mieux connaître notre
planète toutes les évolutions du
changement climatique la possibilité de
cette localisation précises pour la
surveillance des mères le contrôle
aérien avec galileo qui est le gps
européen
tout ça il faut en parler c'est
considérable et en plus aujourd'hui ce
sont des enjeux je dirais de sécurité et
de souveraineté d'autonomie dans la
prise de décision donc c'est essentiel
et ça il faut continuer a vraiment donné
beaucoup de possibilités pour les pour
les développements et puis il ya tout ce
qui est l'exploration la science on
parle de l'exploration habitée c'est une
chose formidable qui permet de continuer
à avancer et vous avez entendu parler
aussi de ses sondes spatiales qui sont
aujourd'hui à destination du soleil de
mercure des exoplanètes
avec ces questions fondamentales de
l'univers le james webb télescope quand
on a parlé à noël dernier toute cette
exploration scientifique
ce sont des questions fondamentales qui
nécessitent d'être portés d'être
financés et d induire bien évidemment et
d'être défendue donc l'espace ça fait
partie de notre vie aujourd'hui et c'est
la construction de demain j'ai des
photos à vous proposer claudie haigneré
c'est aussi un rituel dans cette
émission
la première la voici vous avec jean
pierre raffarin c'est lui qui vous ne
mangez en 2002 ministre déléguée à la
recherche et aux nouvelles technologies
en mars 2004 il vous nommera ministre
délégué aux affaires européennes
est ce que ce sont des postes que vous
avez accepté facilement et tout de suite
quels souvenirs vous gardez de cette
expérience au sein du gouvernement la
politique c'est encore un autre univers
un autre monde qui n'a rien à voir avec
le vôtre a priori alors c'est cet
engagement c'est arrivé tout de suite
après ma seconde mission ont fait
quelque temps après l'atterrissage et
c'était
une réponse à une envie de s'engager
avec des convictions vous avez rappelé
les deux postes auxquels j'ai exercé des
responsabilités la recherche chez un
médecin et un sheikh charger une thèse
de neurosciences j'ai travaillé que le
cnrs sur ces sujets de recherche et puis
je vous ai dit que l' agence française
je suis j'ai ensuite intégré l'agencé
spatiale européenne j'ai volé au nom de
l'europe donc voilà c'est un engagement
par conviction en se en souhaitant
pouvoir
apporter une impulsion faire avancer des
choses et chose qui n'allait pas assez
vite et mission accomplie alors les
missions accomplies partiellement parce
que l'on peut être une une chose de ma
vie d'avant de l'astronaute où j'ai eu
la chance de pouvoir toujours ce que je
voulais je pouvais quand je voulais dans
le monde politique je pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord avec moi
pourquoi le fleuve loire n'est pas
suffisant
dans le monde politique je pense
que j'ai quand même été très privilégiés
protégés par une espèce de aura d'avoir
eu la chance d'aller dans l'espace et
d'avoir une place particulière dans le
coeur et les français une autre photo
claudie haigneré cette faste une photo
du palais de la découverte et la cité
des sciences dont vous avez été
responsable en tant que présidente
d'universcience pendant cinq ans je
crois c'est ça entre 2010 et 2015 ça
représente quoi pour vous ces lieux de
de transmission c'est fondamental oui
alors c'était l'engagement suivant dans
les multiples vies que j'ai eu la chance
de vivre c'était effectivement de se
dire comment aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
donc je considère qu on est quand même
dans des conditions différentes du
siècle précédent comment on parle de la
science de la technologie de
l'ingénierie à la jeune génération et
puis aux parents grands-parents amis qui
accompagnent ces jeunes parce que je
pense que cette éducation cette culture
de la science et de la technique on peut
en avoir une partie à l'école bien
évidemment ça fait partie du socle des
programmes mais qui a aussi tout un
monde une éducation qu on dit un peu
informelle par rapport à celle de
l'école qui est une éducation qui va
inspirer donner des clés aller vers les
merveilles mon la découverte la
curiosité et c'était merveilleux de
pouvoir effectivement essayé de repenser
des grandes maisons aussi belle que le
palais de la découverte la cité des
sciences encore une question et ce sera
ma dernière claudie haigneré elle est en
lien avec le lieu dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui on est entouré de
quatre statues qui représente 4 vertu
celle qui est derrière vous représente
la sagesse celle ci la prudence elle si
la justice est derrière moi l'éloquence
j'ai envie de vous demander laquelle de
ces vertus vous caractérise le mieux où
vous parle le plus
j'ai peut-être répondre la sagesse mais
je reste très humble par rapport à par
rapport à ça bien bien évidemment mais
je pense qu'en en ayant eu la chance
peut-être de prendre du recul et prendre
de la distance d'avoir la chance de
vivre plein de vie des chemins de
travers les réussites et puis les choses
qui étaient moins réussi
voilà ça m'a peut-être prendre un petit
peu de densité et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a la chance d'avoir
plein d'outils de pouvoir être très
intelligent d'avoir delà de la puissance
de la capacité à agir mais qu'il faut
vraiment l'exercer avec sagesse parce
qu'on sait à quel point on a une
responsabilité par rapport à l'ensemble
de l'humanité par rapport à la planète
par rapport à ces pandémies par rapport
à ces mutations donc essayons d'être le
plus sage possible la sagesse ce sera le
mot de la fin est votre votre mot de la
fin à vous merci infiniment claudie
haigneré d'avoir été notre merci dans un
monde un regard merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation et toutes ces
confidences on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro d'un
monde un regard à très bientôt
[Musique]